our special correspondent Alex Crawford
reports from antakia and uh just a
warning there are images of dead people
being pulled out for the rubble and uh
also in the street
help has finally arrived in hattai and
it is now here in bucket loads
but they simply cannot get too much
support here
the relief operation may have been
turbocharged with diggers and heavy
machinery brought in but it's barely
scraping the surface here
so many are still trying to find their
loved ones
answer me my love she says
there is a unique torture in not knowing
and the people of hatai are now horribly
familiar with it
our drone pictures give an indication of
just what they've been through here and
the destruction wrought on just this
city is staggering hardly a buildings
left untouched replicate this over a 500
kilometer area across turkey which is
the earthquake zone and you get a sense
of the scale
so the relatives keeping vigil are
forced to endure this Grim scene
continually bodies being pulled out
repeatedly
the waiting is over for someone each
time only to be replaced by fresh
suffering
volunteers brought van loads of donated
supplies but they seem pitifully
inadequate for the crushing needs here
they're hungry after nothing much for
three days
and many scrambled out of collapsing
homes with just what they were wearing
and are now shivering living out in the
open so warm clothes are eagerly
snatched
and coats are worth fighting for
they've been through a terrible trauma
and it's not over yet
dude what did you manage to escape with
issue nothing nothing I just came out
with my pajamas she says just my pajamas
we left without taking anything
they don't have time to deal with the
large numbers of dead right now so the
corpses are left near where they're
found
roughly a third of Quake deaths in
Turkey have been recorded here in hatai
president erdogan has admitted mistakes
were made early on and many here in
hattai believe their relatives paid the
price for those shortcomings but the
Turkish leader insists no government
could prepare for a disaster this size
[Music]
offers of help from 45 countries but the
first International search and rescue
team we've seen in Hattie is a 77 strong
group of firefighters from Britain
they've come with disaster skills four
sniffer dogs specialized equipment and
lots of Hope
do you think there is still a
possibility that people can be saved at
this point there's always hope and
there's lots of evidence to suggest
people in the right conditions survive
quite some time so yeah that's what
we're here for
and their expertise is much needed as
soon as they're spotted they're asked
for help
[Music]
they're not sure they've been on the
ground for less than half an hour but
the British team are getting ready for
their first search for survivors
the sniffer dogs are crucial and the
teams also brought seismic listening
devices concrete cutting and braking
equipment but it won't be easy
got lots of information
about the type of collapse the type of
survival voids the likelihood of people
in there
about an indication from the dog mate
all we're going to do is recording all
that information now and then deciding
what to send a team here this should be
this one is it is quite dangerous it was
going to take a long time to dig in and
find out there's no clear precise
indications that there's someone live in
there at the moment so that's still what
we're searching for so we're still
looking their expertise is going to be
absolutely critical in this condition
and it's what the area has been crying
out for many of the residents still
coming up to us complaining about how
there's no Mass organized coordination
of this relief effort and they don't
feel there's enough Specialists on the
ground
together tens of thousands have been
left homeless by This Disaster and are
now dependent on donations and
desperately in search of shelter in
mid-winter the numbers in need here are
overwhelming Alex Crawford Sky News in
antakia hatai